if you're not familiar with specs it stands
for special purpose acquisition company here's
how it works let's say you have an up-and-coming
company that wants to go public if you wanted to
do it the right way you would have to go through
a bunch of SEC scrutiny and to pay massive fees to
Simply operate as a public company you'll have
to put out quarterly reports host shareholder
meetings and probably deal with more audits while
this is truly quite annoying for businesses these
regulations are what keep retail investors at
least somewhat safe but what if there was a
way to work around this red tape well there is
enter specs specs are basically shell companies
that will go public in place of the original
company people can invest into this pack and
this pack will turn around and invest into
the original company and given that this pack
is just a shell it's far easier and cheaper
to maintain this packet as a public company